for a country struggling to manage Solid
Waste this recycling plant offers
Nigeria home
it gives discarded automobile tires new
purpose and the factory a steady source
of income
from floor mats to tiles and even
artworks all tires that usually end up
in landfills are now helping to create
jobs and incomes
for the past two years we've walked
mainly with the robber from the tires
that we recycled however we are just
about to commence recycling of the steel
we'll be melting them into smaller
pellets which would then be easier for
us to transport and we have off takers
already waiting to collect this people
will manufacture other things with steel
it's taken three years for the company
to break even
but it's a business with potential
the company has only recycled 400 000
old tires so far which is just a small
fraction of the millions dumped every
year more than half a million tires are
still waiting to be processed within the
factory premises
an estimated 12 million car tires are
discarded every year in Nigeria most end
up in landfills or Burns or reinforcing
wires can be extracted but this startup
is making a lot of money and helping the
environment at the same time
it's a capital intensive project that
requires constant supply of electricity
Nigeria currently generates only 5 000
megawatts for businesses and over 200
million people if we had more support
than we currently have I'm quite sure
that profitability would have been could
have been achieved sooner
environmentally say the government here
must Force manufacturers to recycle
they too should have a plan to ensure
that they are interested in the life
cycle of the attire from manufacture to
its end life where did it get to how did
they impact the environment not just
selling the tire and then looking away
for now the task of treating such
environmentally harmful waste Falls to
small companies like this who lack
either the resources or capacity to cope
with the share volume that pile up at
their doorsteps Ahmed Idris Al Jazeera
ibadan Nigeria